ok I want to talk about this controversy
involving San Francisco 49ers
quarterback Colin Kaepernick who refused
to stand during the national anthem a
few days ago before a football game he
was asked why why wouldn't you stand
during the national anthem and he said
that he was motivated to sit during the
national anthem by the issues of police
brutality as well as racial injustice in
the United States
he had many supporters who liked what he
did and also many many people who were
super angry at him saying oh he's being
unpatriotic
how dare Colin Kaepernick not stand
during the national anthem our soldiers
have fought for our flag and freedom of
expression and then he insults them by
sitting to which I say isn't Colin
Kaepernick having the choice to sit or
stand during the national anthem part of
the freedom of expression that goes with
the flag that our armed our members of
the military are fighting for and for
those who were calling Colin Kaepernick
unpatriotic for pointing out issues that
he sees within the United States think
about that double standard many of the
same people who considered Donald Trump
a patriot for going around saying the
country's on fire it's not great I'm
going to make it great again they think
he's a patriot for that are saying Colin
Kaepernick is unpatriotic for pointing
out what he sees as the failings of our
country why isn't Trump being called the
traitor for saying the country isn't
great anymore I guess that's different
in some way Jason and some people are
attributing this to Oh will Colin
Kaepernick is black and this is just a
racist thing I'm sure there are
individual racists but I think that big
picture that is not at the heart of it
it's just the double standard where
certain critiques of America
particularly when you're criticizing the
first half black president who happens
to be a Democrat it's okay to critique
America then but if it's Colin
Kaepernick critiquing what he sees as
race related in Justices that's not
patriotic that's traitorous yeah you
need a stand
for what you believe in or not stand up
for it I think this is a great thing I
think more athletes should be able to do
this it should be let's take it take us
take a stand or a seat and by that you
know have the media have to ask why
didn't you do this why did you do this
and it opens up a great a great
conversation I'd say I have no problem
with this making headlines and in fact
that's probably the goal if you are
trying to point to injustice as you see
you should have really no problem with
media picking up on the fact that you
set the problem I have is with some of
the specific and hypocritical critiques
of Colin Kaepernick and there's another
story here that we've talked about and
we've talked about this with Dave Zirin
from the nation many times the glaring
corporatism faux patriotism and
militarism of American professional
sports
why do athletes even need to listen to
the national anthem before starting the
game even the president is not required
to listen to the national anthem before
starting their day in most other
countries in many other countries the
national anthem is not played before
sporting events and my last thought on
this even the national anthem itself in
full is sort of a celebration of slavery
a lot of people don't know this but we
only sing part of the national anthem
now let's put up on the screen the third
verse of the national anthem which
references slavery positively saying no
refuge could save the hireling and slave
from the terror of flight or the gloom
of the grave and the star-spangled
banner in triumph doth wave or the land
of the free and the home of the brave
that is the third verse of the national
anthem no refuge could save the hireling
and slave others have jumped in and said
hey wait a second did this actually make
sense I can understand why colin
kaepernick wouldn't stand during this
and then some others have critiqued
colin kaepernick by saying what why is
he even involved in this he's not really
black and also he's rich so who is he to
talk about this stuff that is the
identity politics nonsense Rodney
Harrison
a former San Diego Chargers and Patriots
safety who's now a studio analyst on
Sunday Night Football said I'll tell you
this I'm a black man and Colin
Kaepernick he's not black he cannot
understand what I face and what other
black men and black people face or
people of color face on an everyday
basis this is completely toxic right I
mean whatever Colin Kaepernick's
experience is he's not more or less
allowed to express freedom of speech
based on his income or his perceived
skin color or any other identity factor
we can have a debate over whether Colin
Kaepernick's grievances are valid we can
debate whether the national anthem
should or should not be played before
professional sporting events but
disqualifying Colin Kaepernick as many
have done because he doesn't really look
that black is he black I don't really
know and you know he's a rich guy who
can express these ideas without any real
risk to his career because he has so
much money and makes however many
million dollars a year that is logically
fallacious it has no bearing on the
validity of what he's doing which I
completely support the fact that he's
entitled to do I don't know if you feel
differently Jason no I agree with you
definitely I I'm just wondering why does
Rodney head Harrison have a problem with
this shouldn't he maybe he should be
speaking in in some vein I don't know
him as a you know a spokesman for for
any any issue anti racism racism and
does this discount with this you know is
this kind of the Malcolm X kind of thing
at one point he felt that no white
people should be trying to help with the
minority movements is this the same
rhetoric I think it's kind of dangerous
I don't think it should be oh it's
completely dangerous and I've rejected
it wholeheartedly this is the toxic
identity politics stuff where for
example I was called the white
supremacists because I I had a critique
of some of the tactics used by black
lives matter and because I'm not black I
was actually critiqued and said who are
you to comment on what's going on and I
reject that completely and we've seen
this in many other areas and I think
it's absolutely toxic and ridiculous and
everybody applying that standard to
Colin Kaepernick you're not going to get
very far with that
amongst rational and clear thinking
individuals Gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the David
Pakman show audience and support our
show by going to Gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s